are you going to do all right how are
you doing I'm doing excellent I want to
start by saying this this I it's hard to
say you love a movie when it's something
like this but I was so impressed by this
film and what Anthony did with it
there's a lot to talk about but talk a
little bit about collaborating with
Anthony because I think for his first
feature I'm so blown away by what he did
with us yeah it's real dick I'm making a
movie coming out the gate like this like
what a jerk yeah it's amazing I mean
this is this is for a debut film I don't
know that I've seen one that really
demands your emotional attention so much
I mean you are really at his mercy and
he is merciless and the way he's sort of
like executes this he approached it by
doing years of research and almost
approached it like a documentarian when
we got there when we got to Adelaide we
had weeks of rehearsals and and we sat
down and he had every single news
clipping articles books memoirs
interviews he had all this stuff that we
had that we could dig into this because
this situation is so brutal it's hard to
almost as an actor it's almost
impossible to just sit in your room and
close your eyes and imagine exactly what
this feels like but because of his
diligence we had we had actual
first-hand accounts of people who went
through it and we could sort of glean
from that what we needed to do he did an
amazing job and I think that he came out
of the gate strong as hell yeah well one
of the things that I think is so
effective is that I'm sure like the two
of you I've seen thousands of movies or
I mean just so many but the thing about
this film is it I never knew where it
was gonna go because of the way he shot
it because it's constantly like leaving
you guessing because that's real life he
put real life on screen I just talked a
little bit about what it was like on set
to us to capture that yeah I mean it was
it was a truly as a very surprising
you'll experience this film you know it
took a big toll on all of us you know he
did this thing say that you know your
mind knows you're acting but your body
doesn't anybody doesn't someone said
earlier like that's a good luck yeah but
it's true you know and Anthony had put
speakers around the sets that we were
working in and he had this button in
press and you know you all of a sudden
hear a grenade go off or a gun or and
even in between takes he was using this
thing and it sounds sadistic but
actually you know it was what was
required for this you know to give us
this base layer of tension we weren't in
between takes joking around you know
fooling around you know it required us
to go in feeling this level of anxiety
at every moment you never know what's
gonna happen what's around the corner so
we would be in it for 12 hours luckily
we have lunch breaks and you know we're
actors we get to call cut so it's hardly
what it truly would have been like for
these guys but we tried our level best
to elevate our our present to what it
potentially could have been like if I'm
not mistaken where you shot some of
Slumdog was where one of the incidents
happened in Mumbai
yes yeah yeah so the dark sequence at
the end of Slumdog one of India's most
populated stations Victoria Terminus
some a they they you know it's a big
dance sequence at the end and you just
all the world is you know kind of in awe
of the humanity that is on display in
that last sequence and it's a big
tourist moment to think that you know
after Toronto I mean just celebrated a
twinning there you know very soon after
you come home and you switch on the
television and you see these teenagers
with backpacks and ak-47 senselessly
just killing innocents you know it
really shook me to my core
yeah one of the things about the film
that another thing I think that it did
such a great job is it shows all sides
of this of what happened including why
these terrorists were prime targets for
radicalization can you sort of talk
about that aspect of the film that it
it's not just one-sided if you will yeah
this is the first movie I've ever seen
that really shows the humanity of the
gunman they're not nameless faceless
killing machines
they are children who are miss educated
and and manipulated and lied to and
promised a false bill of goods and and
radicalized in a way that doesn't sort
of segregate by color or whatever I mean
look at all the attacks now that are
happening by white extremists I mean all
of the shootings that have happened in
the last year have been done by white
extremists who were radicalized by just
ludicrous ideas and imaginary
differences between one person and
another you know whether it be how much
melanin your skin has or whatever you
know imaginary border is drawn between
your country and another or whatever it
might be and you see that in these
gunden these are kids these are these
are sad confused kids and doing what
they're doing and perpetrating these
attacks has an effect on them you know I
mean they're there you see how hard it
is on them as well
and the cost that it takes for them to
take life and for them to do these
attacks I mean and and sort of their
motivation behind it which is which is
false and and you know I don't think
I've seen an example of that in film
really yeah yeah it's you know it's the
you know it's the guns won't solve this
situation is what you realize you know
these these kids come from that you know
for the virus to spread you need the
right breeding ground these guys have
access to nothing there you know
anything growing off in situations of
extreme poverty and they think they're
doing it to help their family so you
know you know that that's not going to
change anything you know to really solve
these problems is to go to the root of
the problem you know these situations
the cancer said occation it's it's a
it's about you know educating people on
different cultures and things like that
so I'm yeah you guys are part of a very
lucky group which are both you both
worked with Aaron Sorkin and I'm curious
yeah he did it squared in a way didn't
he twice
I'm just curious his dialogue and the
and getting to work with that kind of a
script I would imagine changes you as an
actor or you learn a lot working with
someone like that who just curiously
what you took away from that experience
for both of you yeah it's tough
Aaron's a genius and you know it's I
mean I was well over my head I'm like
I'm so lucky that he Carrie you didn't
fire me after season five
well you know it's just it really it's
an orchestra his dialogue you know it's
it's never about one person but how
everything sounds in the rhythm and
everyone's jumping on top of each other
there's never breath and until the
moment pays off it really is so
beautifully choreographed the way he
writes um you said it best when you said
it's like it's like music and there's a
rhythm to it it takes a long time to
understand it yeah all of a sudden you
know ah and he so specifically you know
he would come up to go uh uh army army
uh on this line you you you made that in
ellipses and it's not in ellipses it's
clearly a comma make it a comma don't
make it in ellipses and you go what yeah
you're like oh okay comma not a little
easy got it he can you know and
read-throughs when someone's ill and
Aaron reads in for any other role you
life I really mean it congratulations on
this film you were both so incredible in
it have a fantastic day thank you
you